No Mcdonald has had a lot of well wishes
recently and a lot of people that would
like to throw him down. One, uh,
well they want to murder him.
Well,
seems a bit harsh,
but old turd Ferguson is found himself
in a bit of hot water recently and I have
been racking my brain to try and find
out why was it for whipping out his dirty
cock for an Oprah. Was it for
killing his wife and a waiter? Nope.
Instead it was for his incredibly ill
advised decision to speak honestly and an
interview with the Hollywood reporter.
I had initially planned this video to
be an analysis and tribute to norm,
but I now feel the need to address
this crazy stolen Essex show trial.
He's just been dragged through for
his incredibly innocuous comments.
But first I want to explain
to the folks at home my norm,
Macdonald is possibly the greatest
comedic mind in the entire universe.
Great Star got blessing world,
great people. This is wonderful.
Being here at the home
[inaudible]
Don Rickles was the master of the old
timey rose, Dean Martin, Sammy Davis,
Frank Sinatra. Nobody was safe from
the sharp tongue of Mr. Warmth.
It seems so effortless because
funny was simply who he was.
It was just dawn being done.
The roasts of today are very different.
The punchline has become almost irrelevant
and shock factor seems to be all that
matters. When norm as the
producers of comedy central,
what to talk about on a roast,
they told him exactly that to be
as shocking as possible. Of course,
norm knew right away the most shocking
performance he could give and it gave us
one of the greatest
moments in comedy history.
Yes, but of course he was famous
for being a vegetarian. Hey,
she may be a vegetarian, but you're
still full of Bologna in my book.
That's a beautiful face. Like
a flower. Yeah, Cali flower,
no offense,
but your face looks
like a collie flower.
This moment is still talked about in the
world of comedy is one of the ballsiest
things any performer has ever done.
The audience expects,
even demands profanity and nastiness.
Then norm walks up to the podium with all
the confidence in the world and begins
delivering dad jokes.
So exquisitely hokey that they cross over
into the realm of genius to those who
just know norm from weekend update or
his hilariously strange appearances on
late night talk show this.
It can seem like he is slowly
turning into that senile old man.
He's always been pretending to be despite
the fact that he is one of the most
intelligent,
well read people in the world of comedy.
Norm is okay with giving off this persona
of the crazy rambling uncle and for a
very good reason,
his what
he should be doing as being funny.
That should be his goal.
Your friend Bill Maher for instance,
you know,
he wants to be seen as an intellectual,
this Miller, Dennis Miller,
but a Letterman, but Letterman understands
he's smarter than both of them.
He understands. Play
the dumb guy, you know,
play the play, the play, the every man.
Nobody likes a guy smarter than them.
That's the worst.
The worst guy. You can be a
guy smarter than the audience.
They're going to hate you, you know?
Yeah. It's a very good observation
and just in case you thought he
really was that. See now old man,
he often seems to be,
feel free to test his wit off the cuff
and I slept at the parking lot.
Oh,
the comedy store and I had no
money and I was broke. Both. Yeah.
You are making a movie with carrot top
right? I made a movie with carrot top.
Okay. All right. It's like nine
and a half weeks, but carrot top.
Wow.
I got to check out that movie you
called nine and a half seconds
movie going to be called. I know
it's going to be called. Yep.
What's that?
If it's got carrot top and it, you know
what a good name for it. B. What's that?
Norm box office poison
from Mcdonald's. God
bless. You're watching.
Your set was like watching
Henry Fonda pick blueberries.
Why?
I don't think there's a person in here
there would not love to watch Henry Fonda.
Big Boy
movie coming out. Yes, title undetermined
at this point. Chairman of the board.
Wow. All right. Do something
with that. You can breed.
I,
I've had the board is spelled Bor.
Yeah.
If you try and tell your favorite norm
McDonald joke to a friend where you will
find as you stand there in
awkward silence is the norms.
Delivery is one of the most
important factors to a success.
He's mastered the ability to
keep the audience off balance.
You're expecting a short joke.
He gives you a long one.
You're expecting a clever punchline.
He gives you a simple one.
You're expecting him to be dumb.
He makes it profound and sincere statement
norm has devoted his entire life to
finding out what it will take to delight
and surprise the audience. Every pause,
every expression, every delivery he makes
is always with the punchline in mind.
When you launched into his joke and most
of the credit is wondering if this guy
has any idea what he's doing,
those who know him understand that the
innocent looking smile means that he is
an absolute control of what's happening.
If you watch norm long enough,
you will have no choice
but to conclude the,
he's one of the most loving and
caring people in all of show business.
If you want to see evidence of this,
you need only to look at him tearing up
in his last appearance on Letterman or
watch him crash.
The set of Conan,
not long after Conan learns that he's
losing the tonight show to Jay Leno.
According to someone who is at the show.
Conan was shaking the entire
time when the band spoon played.
He held up their vinyl to introduce
him and he was shaking even more.
Didn't nor makes his surprise appearance.
Well, I want to drop by show my
respects, you know. Well, you know,
for you to bring up a basket
commemorating sort of the, the,
the tough situation I'm in is really nice.
Hello Salad.
That is well, what, what, what does
this basket or this is an older basket.
I a I procrastinate as you
know, and uh, this is a basket.
I got you back in June.
No,
you've had this basket since
June. Yeah, I've seen you.
You've been on the show like three times.
Why didn't you ever give me the basket?
I keep forgetting,
but I wanted you to know I bought it.
It was $60. I wouldn't open
it. I think it would smell.
Okay.
Why does a card also I, yeah, I
see that it congrats. Yeah, that's,
that's terrific. Oh, I don't know if
that, can I read it? Yeah. Why not?
Congratulations Conan and finally securing
your place as permanent host of the
tonight.
Sure.
That's something that
could never take away.
It is perhaps the shrewdest
programming decision ever.
It made me see a brain trust.
Sure. The pressure is on, but
if I know you, Conan O'brien,
miserable failure is not an option yet.
The new late night.
Thank you.
Yeah.
He delivers this absolutely hilarious
bit and is able to make a hard situation
so much lighter through laughter
after seeing how kind norm can beat.
It's so hard to see him being dragged in
front of the view to apologize for his
comments,
which were so much less controversial
than the ones made by that Holocaust
denying sidekick of his in the
Hollywood reporter interview.
He first says that he's happy.
The me too movement has slowed down
a bit and felt that people like Chris
Hardwick got the raw end of the stick.
He also talks about how we set up a call
between Lucy Keen Roseanne because they
had the unique experience of having the
careers ended in one fell swoop and that
the victims did not experience
the same thing. Twitter,
a place which has mastered the art of
interpreting everything in the worst
possible way took this to mean that norm
thinks Louie and Rosanne had it worse
than the me two victims. He may have
been guilty of a poor choice of words,
but if you allow him to explain himself,
that is very clearly not what he meant.
He simply felt bad for his friend Roseanne
and didn't know who could relate to
her situation other than Louie.
What happens after this?
His appearance on the tonight show was
canceled after Jimmy Fallon staffers were
apparently in tears. Come on, man,
as a brittle spirit and he had to go
under the view, not only to apologize,
but to apologize for his
previous apology on Howard Stern.
I said,
not many of us have gone through this
and and so you should talk to each other
because you've you. And then the guy said,
what about the victims? And I said, well,
the victims haven't gone through this.
I was talking about this particular event.
Of course the victims have
gone through worse than that,
but I want to get a victim
to phone Roseanne. No, but
that's a good clarification.
I don't want to be tossed in with
people that actually did not crimes,
but since our, you know, I, uh, no,
I barely have consensual sex.
I can't believe nor for apologizing
because none of us know what it's like to
feel that kind of social
pressure being put on you.
And most of the people hitting on norm
by saying he cooks out by apologizing or
the same people who would crumble if they
had to step on stage for even an open
mic night. It takes insane balls to do
it. Norm has done throughout his career.
But getting the apology from
him is crucial for those
who are trying to drag the
names of norm and others through the mind.
The best analogy I can make us to
Arthur Miller's play the crucible.
It is set in the hysteria
of the Salem witch trials.
The accused are given two options,
admitted their crimes in live or
deny wrongdoing and be executed.
The people who signed the false
confessions to save their life soon.
Find out that those holding the trials
are using the confessions as validation
and proof that the trials
being held are just,
and their decision to confess is actually
helping them condemn their friends who
are denying the charges
levied against them.
Let us throw open the floor
to a wild accusations.
There are three steps which take place
in these media and Twitter. Witch hunts.
Step one,
the person must have something to lose.
They must believe that not admitting
guilt will land them in a worse situation
than there are now. Step two, you get
them to confess to their wrongdoing,
which gives validation to the inquisition
that is being held by his admission of
guilt. Your actions as accuser have now
been justified in the mind of the public.
You can either proceed with the planned
execution in this case that would be
protesting his show until it's
canceled or by your own mercy.
You will allow him to soak back with
his spirit thoroughly crushed if he
promises now,
were you thinking twice before?
Yeah,
and it gets out of your mouth.
The beauty of someone like norm is that
he says exactly what comes to his mind
without thinking about how
his words will be interpreted.
If this man loses his will to speak
freely out of fear of repercussions,
it would be a travesty and we would have
destroyed perhaps the greatest comedian
of our generation.
The firestorm quickly died this time,
but it doesn't mean that others
will be so lucky in the future.
I'm glad to see the most,
the internet seems to be on norm side
with this as a man of true comedic
integrity,
he has always refused to compromise and
has constantly risked everything to tell
the truth. And while it may have
held him back from the stardom,
he could have attained,
it has earned him a permanent place
as one of comedies all time greats,
woody Allen.
And they went on stage and a lot of
the people did much better than him.
And he was upset and his manager said,
no, no, it's what you leave on a stage.
That was his remark upon
woody Allen. And so, uh,
I always thought, well, I guy like
Andrew dice clay would destroy,
you know, and have me hitting the
wall, as you say. But then afterwards,
maybe it feel a little queasy,
whereas you kill and then you
leave something nice on the stage.
You know, it's one thing to make people
laugh. It's another to make people smile.
Wow.
Thank you guys for watching.
You can support nor by checking out
his special in his new show on Netflix.
If you want to support this channel
as well, I will link to his book,
which you can get for free when you
sign up for a 30 day trial at audible.
Cool.